My name is Manolo Diaz and
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of Yogome, a startup
that develops
mobile educational games
for kids ages six to 11.
We are based here in
Mexico City but we also
have offices in Silicon Valley.
Actually the
company's from the US,
but we increased the production
team, developers, illustrators
here in Mexico City.
In terms of mobile games,
there's a lot of competition,
and we think it's fair for users
to try our games first and then
decide if they want to get
the full version of one
of our games, especially
since we are a new studio.
Now some people know
Yogome, but compared
to Disney or other competition,
we are actually nothing
so we have to show the user
and the parents our quality.
So that's why our games
at the beginning are free,
and then if kids want to
continue playing the game,
parents have to pay for the
full version of the game.
And so far that has
been working really good
so we are very
happy of doing that.
There's a lot of
things that you have
to consider when you're
part of a start up.
But don't take too much
time thinking about that,
just go after it.
Something that has
helped us in the process
is trying to focus on
what we really want to do.
There's a lot of
opportunities out there.
clients that want
to take your games into another
market or try different stuff,
but if you don't focus you're
going to lose a lot of time.
And when you're small, when
you have a limited budget,
you have to understand
what next milestone
you need to accomplish in order
to show that your product is
working, in order to get that
seed round, that series A.
So just try to understand
what works best for you
and just go after that.
And be open.
Share your project,
share your idea.
Don't worry about, hey, they
are going to steal my idea.
That doesn't happen.
There's a lot of work
to do with execution.
It's what makes a difference.
Ideas-- there's dozens
of ideas, but if you
focus on the execution and
you know what you need to do
and you share with more people
and you invite more people
to be part of the
team, I'm pretty
sure you can accomplish
really great things.